en un refugio temporal no lejos del
monte semeru estas personas que han sido
evacuadas disfrutan de una comida
caliente son algunos de los avaneces
desplazados por la erupción del volcán
del pasado fin de semana la casa de este
hombre fue completamente destruida
markito mi casa fue afectada
roma/ap el techo destruido vean a ve
abrir la puerta y hacía mucho calor boca
dentro para nada pero luego decidí huir
lugar se halla
tres días después de la erupción esto es
lo que queda de los pueblos que rodean
el monte semeru cultivos destruidos
árboles derribados casas demolidas y
todo cubierto de ceniza gris
hasta ahora casi 4.000 personas han sido
evacuadas de la zona el presidente en
donde se oyó como y todo visitó el lugar
el martes prometiendo reforzar los
esfuerzos de rescate y recuperación así
como la reubicación permanente para
algunos residentes que apoyan
previamente me informaron que hay unas
2.000 casas que deben ser reubicadas
pronto decidiremos dónde será la
reubicación y las construiremos
inmediatamente
el volcán ha permanecido activo desde el
sábado poniendo en vilo a los residentes
y a los socorristas sin embargo la
búsqueda de sobrevivientes continúa y
los equipos han desplegado perros para
ayudar a la operación el lunes los
equipos desenterraron el cuerpo de un
niño de 13 años y al menos una docena de
personas siguen desaparecidas